hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to going home now this is a
pixelated style horror game that should
explore a lot of multiple possibilities
it's supposed to have multiple endings
based on the choices that I make and I
don't know how in depth that goes but I
always like an opportunity for my
actions to really impact the game music
by Brandon Oh way to go Brandon ah
art by Brandon hey good job Brandon oh
man you're doing great you're doing
everybody proud a game by Brandon I'll
come on Brandon you can do no better hi
Alex
I'm here where are you - why is it so
dark in here the storm must've caused
the blackout good thing I brought my
flashlight alright why am i meeting Alex
and Claire here okay okay
Oh am I supposed to be doing something
here oh ah I don't like that that
actually sends chills up my spine Oh
bright hello how do i I have to find
them first am I gonna find their bodies
oh I have a funny feeling finding their
bodies here
okay I have to find them first okay I
get it I'm at breathing so weird okay I
get it
look let me find him
all right I don't know where my friends
are but I bet they're dead
I gotta admit for meeting low-res this
is legitimately creepy I don't like the
flashlight mechanic because I know
you're gonna hide stuff in the darkness
from me
there's a basketball hoop in there
goddamn place it's locked I need to find
the key hello teddy bears at a body
okay that's his toys and lifti Lou's
also known as weights we are are they I
have to look for them what was that I
have to find them quick all right okay
this is the shelf
oh very observant look inside sure oh
you've got the revolver part it's a
barrel there's nothing more here okay
all righty then I got a revolver part I
don't know I this is a shoe rack it's on
the tenant for some time check inside
just worn out shoes how inside a shoe
rack can you look
excuse you you want to tell me what that
was huh all right I don't like this oh
oh sit down
when I sit down I have nothing to do
goddamn right I have nothing to do oh
these are colorful sticky notes in a
picture of me and my wife with our child
oh just foods trash bin it's full smells
terrible check inside maybe there's a
matchstick all right
large apparatus for this kitchen these
are shelves on top drawers on the bottom
gives you stuff placeholders and a sink
check the drawers yes surrealist
painting it's literally weird stare at
it okay let's do that no one understands
it no one understands me an abstract
painting quite bothering creeps me out
good then we'll both be creeped out okay
I don't know how I got here on a child
crib small paper drawings check it
a child's art I guess
house someone fell off the roof o MF h f
MF h f MA I don't know what this means
but it's a puzzle mom fell hit face
I don't know having a full clothes
handbags Terzi tops lakhs as a
compartment open it shirt boy toy hammer
I guess that's good for me
I want to use it hammer things more toys
stuffed always doll dumbbell who is a
box arm air pump so annoying is the lock
one right I don't know these are candle
holders light it sure okay
something clicked hello what are you the
drawer sure I get a revolver part I got
a cylinder fur oh why do I need a gun
still locked okay I still have to find
the key but at least I lit those hi okay
no okay no okay fine that's sports ball
quite less bouncy
maybe I should pump air sure okay use
the air pumper I got the basketball
there was a basketball hoop over there
why is my house full of puzzles I don't
know that's my knees are tired sit down
no I'm good are you doing that to me
don't do that to me
large sellers
women part some are still working others
are just junk search through it ok
nothing useful here great that was a
waste of my time and yours safe vault
need a combination of the combination B
I don't even know how to use this
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 containing nuts
bolts nails and more certs inside ok
nothing useful here
alright fine then it's gonna be
shouldn't yeah I'm not gonna sit down on
this house
basketball hoop but the net is tied up
put a ball in it sure clicked oh my god
come on I need to get down there brace
and stare at it sure it's beautiful oh
this one's a nice one the other one is a
death one this one fine portrait of an
animal head - lion quite control you
break it sure you use the hammer that
toy hammer did a doozy on that one the
painting fell holes look like slashes
the boxes over check inside what box
okay alright then I picked up the key so
I can go unlock that door up there yes
okay so one more room over if he's doing
bag to want to stop okay
use the key it opened now okay where oh
I don't like that I have to find them
quick the flashlight won't last
Alex okay good find out quick frame and
remember something taking off sure it's
too hard it's too bad looks like it's
been used check under it okay there's a
key is a spatula keychain oh it's to the
kitchen is that what it is
mmm
good okay oh my god I can't see that
there's a mm-hmm nothing else here okay
I gotta go to the kitchen oh I'm gonna
go this way
oh okay I got a guy come on come on no
no no no topper and ammo no mm-hmm me in
the kitchen you sack of [ __ ] okay here
we go shelves on top see check the
drawers yes there's a crowbar oh okay
pick that up so I can go back up to the
bedroom and then I can place it on the
thing they know what's here all right so
if I just keep going over there shoot my
whooping it's clear please let it stay
clear
regularly check the attic in battle the
letters are smudged there's a tiny lever
pull it sure
Oh something foul what is that Zack it's
a rope at least in the Attic pull it yes
ladder fell all right what is that it's
a corpse wizard corpse touch it sure
[Music]
going up random pixels how there's no
electricity turn it off
sure won't turn off okay I'm going up to
the attic leads to the Attic your
Grandpa's old clock I remember it's now
working when grandpa died last autumn
it's working now something's not right
open it sure I must input the
computation I don't know the common
cobwebs and dust all over open it sure
it's like of course it is what else I
don't like these two our room go down
sure I got nothing else to do so I got
to keep going forward
alright go the other way now hey there
my lovely wife so if I go back to the
kids room and I look at the drawings
there must be like if I solve that
puzzle
this must be it so it must relate to
this
so mom fell and then mom fell his fault
mom fell his fault
Oh mom fell his fault so that must be
the code there we go
got it okay got that it's safe all they
need a combination I just opened it
you got the row you've got the revolver
part it's the hammer all the parts I
need a table to rebuild it no one here
okay so I just got to go over to the
kitchen and do this I think kitchen
table nothing special sit down yes
rebuild the revolver rebuild the gun
here so do it
Oh done it felt like ages you've got a
revolver okay all righty then so now
what oh oh that's why all the things
were the same exact answer the whole
time oh look at it oh there's a note if
visions eat that's a book of the Bible I
think which ah okay Ephesians is the
tenth book so Ephesians 2:8 might mean
1028 on the clock and if that's the case
then I should be able to put it in there
but I'm not out of that sure now that I
know my navigation skills are working
properly I can't believe I've gotten
through the whole game by doing that
that's amazing
yes okay so if I can go to tan - wait
there's a key inside ah you get the
clock key so they did work that's so
weird that I have to go into it twice oh
[ __ ] is that
oh my god [ __ ]
[Music]
faint sound wait what happened did I die
mom dad had a neighbor what is happening
shops what is happened
oh hi okay oh this oh look at me go I'm
a wild one there in the Attic I can't
reach the ladder okay
alright then I guess I'll go on my way
it looks a lot it looks a lot simpler
now that uh now that everything is out
in the open so what what in the world
did that do it's a chair Oh take it it's
too big okay let's push it I will just
push it a boo [ __ ] all the way booshed
is sufficiently I can now reach the
ladder go up hello why are you up here
I get it
I'm still alive aren't I
I remember now oh do you oh you remember
he killed her then I do I I can't
remember all I I can't stop can't stop
why I have to look for - okay all right
oh I'm back I guess cool so what do I do
use the clock key you've opened it okay
so am I gonna hit the bottom this
mystery Rose is gonna haunt me forever
look you got a car another key okay key
to the basement now we know what we need
to avoid okay okay all right then gotta
go la-dee-da deep down to the Dottie
Duty's basement Oh
oh that was a close one
oh it's much more threatening when I
can't see it's unlocked oh great so now
what oh boy where am I now
oh lordy Lou it's a toolbox search for
items sure you found a battery great I
don't know why I need that but okay how
extensive
[Music]
it's an ammo box there's only one ammo
here loaded sure you've loaded the mo
what is that have I gotten any mercy
what brings you here
family you only got us we're your family
hahaha are you insane
you've killed her it's you that caused
everything you only you're one crazy son
she was still alive you've ended her
misery
you took it didn't you ha ha I'm so
confused
you thought you could save her with your
foolishness
you thought you could I mean I went is
this is this his dad I think that's who
this is I'm inclined to wait
I don't know what that's gonna change
what are you I know what are you idling
there that bullet was waiting there the
whole time
come on kid shoot me why what are you
waiting for come on kid pull the trigger
she loves you more than me it's you
you killed her if it was not for your
stupidity she would not have fell I
didn't mean to shove her I was mad but
you because of you she fell no shoot me
so I could be with her
are you listening to me stop thinking
start shooting I ain't going to forget
what you did please just shoot me I want
to live what I can't bear this leave me
alone okay
what was that okay all right well you
stay there I guess Oh wouldn't happening
oh boy
like this hi hello I just got home mom
how are you please
oh hi okay that's weird
don't come closer to me no thank you I
don't want mom are you alright I think
mom is alright did something happen
I think you're out of your goddamn mind
dad he's resting
I I did not do anything he's safe mom
what are you are you angry stop don't
come any closer
what the hell is with you and this gun
nut stop
why because of him you died so why I'm
gonna shoot why do I have a say in this
matter
[Music]
stop okay I guess I don't what the hell
ending saving home total playtime wait
too long 40 minutes what in the [ __ ]
yeah what ending was that Brandon
Brandon I have no idea what just
happened I am at a complete loss and I
have no idea I have no idea well that's
just something that we're gonna have to
deal with okay there you have it so
anyway that was going home that was a
Mindwarp of a game and yet it was
extremely simplistic I understand that
it was extremely simplistic I can like
look past that because what it did with
what it had was really really good like
the ambience was there and I enjoyed it
immensely from that the puzzling was a
bit like it dragged on a bit but even so
I don't know what the other endings are
I don't know if what I got was a good
ending which I kind of liked I like the
ambiguity of it and the mystery of the
story can be pieced together by finding
the other endings but even so it was a
bit monotonous to go through again but
either way hope you guys enjoyed it let
me know what you think down in the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]